how's Gomes my name's beard we're
playing Katherine oh my god I love this
game so much we're pleased we're we're
on the fifth day it's a stray sheep
let's let's enjoy some Cuba Libre
num-num num-num great way wasn't her
what's going on here I think I hear fans
out my house they're giggling alright
well then let's go up and talk to the
twins we haven't talked to these two
beautiful ladies for a while would you
like to speak to Martha yes Martha in
particular as a dog do you see yourself
as a cat uh woof meow oh damn it
do you know about ants like the [ __ ]
kind of question is that
well we did see ants before what look
there was just a rumor
what the [ __ ] what
if ants are the messages for witches
there was an end when we cheated the
first time with the other Catherine so
that means the first Catherine is a
witch good nay nay ye you have any
messages hey how's it going Vincent what
are you doing right now
I can't reply to it for some reason that
makes me very sad interesting let's keep
talking to our friends I enjoy just
hanging out at the bar it makes me feel
like I actually have friends this is
fantastic but Erika a lot of problems
back in the day remember that time she
was hurt by a relationship and
disappeared huh what what happened I
remember that and people were saying she
was dead but then she just popped up out
of nowhere he knew Erika had some trauma
like that in her past but I'll fill
every hole in her heart
no I'll fill every hole in her heart hey
I'm serious here it'll make fun of me
and in her body too what
oh so Toby's in love with Erika at the
waitress that's Kawhi Catherine isn't
cheating why are you even downing
give me bad yeah your own size in the
first place but and why don't you break
up yeah why don't you break us you think
she's watching there's not a single good
reason why we're still with the first
Catherine to just sit there getting
angry I'm not except that she's pregnant
actually news I just remembered you've
got mail
let's check the mail I'll still be doing
a work he's fine I can trust him to
customize a bike without watching over
him you should spend more time tinkering
with chicks not bikes oh he needs to
hook up with somebody good for someone
besides Erica yes so good of the little
guy about sharing some of that love with
us oh my god I feel like I'm part of a
friendship group this is so nice
I feel like I have friends this is thank
you we've completed stage 5
that means there's 3 more stages and
then we'll see what happens
um it's my first playthru I really want
to play this game again and do like good
choices after but we're doing bad choice
let's talk to this gentleman Archie
my boss he's dead Oh Oh waste it away
he was talking about those strange
dreams not gonna die like in the rumors
if I don't wake up from this nightmare
am I gonna die
probably having those nightmares too I
can't remember but I see them I knew it
she's the witch she cursed me when I
said I couldn't marry her that's what
those dreams are about dude don't worry
about it they're just rumors why why did
he have to die
so there is definitely a witch involved
in this love triangle drama
thingamajigger Catherine with a K and
Catherine with a C eat that piece of
cake I gave you or it's going to get
stale I know we couldn't talk about
yesterday I've been busy with work and
it's hard to make time I might not be
able to pick you up the phone sometimes
I'll give you a call soon
I'll tell you more later I'm pretty
tired so I'll talk to you later okay
doesn't really make [ __ ] sense okay
radda radda right here's something that
um
that'll make you feel what well is it
working what oh sorry I'm sending that
one while you were at work I hope I
didn't get you in trouble anyway let's
take care what you look at this in
public you could check this out
somewhere work okay I'm getting a little
tired of the whole bathroom going
situation so we're not gonna do that
today we are however we're gonna sit
down and talk to these two because I
think they are the closest clue to the
couple's Daniel don't be like that
they're awful kind of Vincent why don't
you hook up with him I can't be with you
right
so everyone wins yeah it's no use being
with a man who will just become somebody
else's hey guys if you're gonna get hurt
then why did you bring this up do you
have any idea how I feel when I buy my
clothes I have to save everything I make
just to buy handbags and clothes that
will embarrass you when we're seeing
together I studied economics and
etiquette every day just so I wouldn't
embarrass you at an important dinner but
it's all pointless because no matter how
much I better myself it'll never be good
enough for some people you know
it was inevitable that we breakup from
the beginning I'm sorry I never let you
give me any presents I had to do
something to keep my dignity
um is that what you really want this
isn't about what we want or don't want
well that's complicated Catherine with a
c' is wondering something is it true
that you have a tummyache you're not
lying to me are you hiding anything from
me are you
let's just reply to this one now that's
the wrong no that's the wrong that's the
right all right well as close as an end
cookin yeah do we have a different bar
for Catherine with a seein Katheryn
Winnick a let's talk to the bar turning
and then we'll get out it's awful
wearing what you can see my back from
there I was making crack monkey on your
back I forget you look stressed see my
girlfriend might be cheating oh my
you're cheating yourself
and yet you're this concerned about your
lovers for death ha ha ha
I want to believe but it's just it's
secure all the mistakes of the woman or
the fault of the map to cop a phrase
from a certain someone
no wait and that's not really much
consolation is it we're drinking forget
not knowing something is as if it never
occurred this guy is my favorite you got
me Catherine with a K did something
happen
I hope I'm imagining things oh yeah I'm
meeting with a friend tomorrow see if
you want to call me do it in the
afternoon aren't you busy with work -
trying to get easy okay okay well let's
krippcat damn I'm not lying
seems fine
Yeah right oh good all right we need to
talk to Catherine with the K and but
let's finish our drink because I want
some trivia actually be cheating on me
yes this is so here's some trivia for
you as you leave that finished class all
right lay it on me
chugging alcohol isn't good for you but
sometimes it's necessary why
the cocktail in ecologica is an example
of this it uses cognac lemon coffee and
sugar but by why first you put the lemon
coffee and sugar in your mouth then you
take a big swig of cognac of course you
can't even talk until you drink it all
it's necessary to chug it
but cognac contains 40 percent alcohol
so those with low health shouldn't and
that was the cocktail tribute I'm gonna
try any galosh guy or wherever it's
called I never heard of that drink that
sounds [ __ ] awesome I know I don't
want another drink is there an option
not to get another drink Jesus Christ
coming right I do like the idea that I
finish my drink and then I'll eat you
but I guess there's no way to do that
alright let's keep playing res I'm sorry
if I take too long in these I feel like
it's part of the game I know don't you
think that everyone's acting I don't
know strange lately
not just you yeah it's the witches you
worried about those rumors you shouldn't
get yourself so worked up about that
stuff I don't believe in any of that you
see it
okay apparently we don't believe in any
of the hedgerows I believe I believe I
believe there'd every day it's a
beautiful day I believe I believe
now we're gonna fall asleep again and
probably have a bad nightmare you know
Katherine right wouldn't be surprised
always meeting new people for work we're
so shit-faced Jesus it's gonna be bad
Bryce it's gonna be bad we're just going
to sleep that's it like I played this I
play this already nightmare time six day
I rat a rat alright it's time to be
cheap and have some sheep shake okay but
I think there was a joke somewhere there
um I wonder how this level is gonna look
like look how far we come just from our
little sheep egde we do have a kind of a
climb left though clock tower cool
skills will be tested by their various
puzzles bomb blocks are lit when you
walk over them and the damnit okay
that's kind of cool
see how that goes pocket [ __ ] love
and by this time we're honest there's
still more
the puzzle in this game is just [ __ ]
genius it's gonna blow up
I don't know it's so [ __ ] cool like I
just don't enjoy the gameplay sorry that
the story the puzzle part is [ __ ]
awesome - how many puzzle games inside
which is a shame because I really like
them climb two steps that's [ __ ]
awesome how does I even work it's real
see eventually why not make it easy for
you what what are these are those are
bombs okay well one of those are they're
cracked and okay doing good will this
break oh it will
genius pips strikes again might as well
pull you up babe at bay there why is
this here just tempting me to walk on it
I'm so glad I selected easy to play off
there's some part where I just been
genuinely stuck even though it's easy
and I don't even want to think about it
did say unless you have played this game
before you should play uneasy so [ __ ] it
I'll do that my next playthrough on
unnormal calm your [ __ ] pants Jesus
Christ they're vibrating tell them to
stop
Oh God are we okay whoa look at that
here we go
doing good the game is telling me I'm
cool and [ __ ] that's not the move I
ordered oh I'm all man I love it so much
mate oh how did it Jeff oh god what the
[ __ ] oh I'm [ __ ] right that [ __ ] ah
wasn't ready for that
obviously with my female shriek I think
it's kind of self-explanatory here we go
how will this affect anything nothing
great
beautiful
I'm thinking too much right now
feel like I could easily [ __ ] up here
but I refuse sorry I'm thinking like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] on a stick there we go
did it have five breath it's my tongue I
found my tongue please do it thank you
thank you so much okay doing good pretty
flawless I would say
I'm worried about this this doesn't look
good
the [ __ ] do I do now
no don't don't no don't don't do that
hey MA
it's what you get good all you lucked
out you can't go up now
Kenny good [ __ ] that actually made me
[ __ ] sweat and [ __ ] we got a nice
combo going can we keep it yep almost at
the top rose if you get a checkpoint I
don't even remember yes yes okay cool
a guy [ __ ] me what do I do now go down
out of my town [ __ ] no [ __ ] me you
[ __ ] dick face come here [ __ ] okay
[ __ ]
can you stop he's mean
[ __ ] can you move oh my god no no no
can I use my spell come on I had it come
on man
[ __ ] Oh omelette I love it so much
we [ __ ] block me oh god here we go
don't [ __ ] up worth it okay are we done
with him now you can't [ __ ] us over or
some [ __ ] put that there
yes beautiful mamacita Oh God
oh that was so close oh my god
okay almost there let's use it
look at that [ __ ] oh my god how long
does it last the [ __ ] is that ability
keep [ __ ] using it
look at it whoa yeah I fibrous but that
was [ __ ] sweetest [ __ ] that was
awesome they have [ __ ] seen items o
pious [ __ ] damn
this better be a gold come on baby come
on give me a nice sweet gold rose
what's that [ __ ] this bronze that net
hurts it hurts a little bit
we had like a sweet combo I don't
understand how well you can't have
everything you want in life bro it's
okay sometimes you just have to look at
what you have and be like alright I'm
gonna save here because this is a good
part to save and then I'll I'll cry
later when no one is watching and it's
not on camera crying on camera is not a
good idea unless I and unless I don't I
can't think of any unless okay here we
go
this is a clock tower 6-piston really
good you've been going in a pace of one
floor per night so far isn't that the
point
hurry up and ask your question I want to
get this over with tonight this is the
eighth question damn calm down you do if
you found out that your significant
other was cheating on you
your lover is cheating on you do you
break up with them make them end it
which one make it them end it what does
that mean I break out with him obviously
how's that a nice thing
I see do you remember what I told what's
that there is someone who put you here
yeah whatever this place is isn't it a
dream that's why even smallest of fears
and doubts become magnified
yeah like the [ __ ] baby and the
marriage thing we got that already
alright you're have to tell us that now
okay sweet doing well bros I hope you're
still enjoying it I'm having a lot of
fun playing this game let's see what
boys answered most people break up with
them same it's funny how few of the
questions about relationship barriers
between male and female it doesn't look
like much and I keep running second
floor there are gaddamn of bum blocks
with different last radio okay rightly
they glow we'll help you figure out
which thank you thank you sexy man voice
I appreciate your help here we go
am I ready no why would I be okay this
looks pretty simple
kind of want them damn it you did a peds
[ __ ] genius peered strikes again what
am I doing with my life
what is what is this something needs to
be changed in Oh God we're so close okay
how do we do this without [ __ ] out
let's use our brain power bros together
yeah I'm out of ideas what about you
bros I feel like I should move this
there
Oh God
and then if I move this here and then
push this away and that should fall down
and then I push you away oh my god
[ __ ] where's my Einstein I mean
where's my Nobel Prize where is it did
you not see that [ __ ] genius pills oh
my god
I'm so proud of me I'm gonna buy myself
a cookie later because I deserve it that
[ __ ] [ __ ] good that's just amazing
I'm crying internally oh we have one
more are you kidding me all right well
this is a good time to save as any Jesus
Christ though we have so much money
should we buy some items yeah why not
they really make it a lot easier and I
hate getting stuck I don't mind getting
stuck if I'm playing by myself but if I
know other people are watching tonight's
product is yeah definitely I'll buy this
thank you mr. fat cheap who are you oh
it's our friend voice
man easy [ __ ] - never mind actually I
think I might know why does he say have
a lot higher to climb work we're on day
six I wasn't that much should I trade
some techniques huh I feel like it's
boring for your bro bros to watch even
though I wouldn't want to do it no I
will not suck your [ __ ] dick sheep
cheese rookies upper talking well good
talk mate good talk
where the [ __ ] did you get that mace by
the way that's amazing
can't even [ __ ] commit to my notes
seems you're getting used to the machine
based traps as well hey doing pretty
good but those sheep that attacked me ah
yes there are many sheep like that now
they've lost their sanity if you lose
your mind all you have left to lose is
your life that makes sense in the real
world anymore
you serious I am serious this ninth
question [ __ ] how did that happen order
lying or being lied to
neither being lighting yeah it is my
choice what about you bris you're in the
middle of the Clocktower stage from the
next section on your trials will get
longer and longer I figured
then hurried the hell up I'll get out of
here before the night is over very well
I'll take you to the next level thank
you so much corny boys how does this
elevator even work I bet there's like
Easter eggs and [ __ ] in this game being
lied to is harder according to men and
women well there you go
the pie chart says it all oh my god we
have [ __ ] two more this is gonna be
one long-ass [ __ ] episode it's oh my
god use the items to your advantage I
always use the items calm down
sexy voice man commencing area clock
tower I see it now that's [ __ ]
awesome
well that work diesel no no no no no I
bought that you know I'm gonna kill
myself
sorry oh my god a lot of trihard that
went into that one Jesus Christ hahaha
this game is really
I took me a lot of trials I'm not gonna
lie uh-huh I'm not gonna keep that [ __ ]
in that's not gonna be fun for anyone to
watch but Jesus Christ I'm glad that's
over I think there's one more Eamon I
don't know how much you brood I feel
like I already showed so much puzzle
this episode I want to get to some story
you know
let's talk to our friend again wait
there's more
I'm gonna throw my back out I'm glad you
made it up all right
it's like my hands are just moving on
their own now don't know how I got so
good at climbing this stuff okay
time n good damn it why did he go away
all of a sudden where did he go hey shut
up I can hear you
sorry yeah I understand and chase around
my Reardon I won't go there's another
big one waiting to greet you tonight oh
god is there oh yeah there's a boss now
all right let's answer this question and
do the boss yeah yeah
bow your cool care with little speech
you have hurry up I'm rigging with a
pissed-off are 9 question what do you do
when you receive a phone call from
someone you don't like
well that's obvious straight to
voicemail
[ __ ] that guy ha ha ha seesee just
shutout people you don't like before I
start getting nervous for no reason you
will be attacked by something oh man
what's what should it be it's probably
gonna be the hot Catherine I mean
Catherine with a st. Catherine with the
C and is his that girl wonder wonder
what's the real Catherine
deep philosophy physical questions
English uh-oh alright girls
answer less boys answer more huh
interesting I never seen a big
difference on these questions
um and I expect that part our final four
we can do it brows say it with me say it
we can I'm so sorry this is annoying
um okay I bet it's gonna be Katherine
with us see what is it daddy oh my god
child with a chainsaw well I would not
have guessed a child with a [ __ ]
chainsaw you're right you got me like me
how fast is this thing I guess we gonna
find out
[ __ ] these slow ass blocks too
yeah I think we're just gonna have to be
fast this is not a thinker this is a
drinker am i right ladies
I'm all right no all right
sorry
why did I do that I don't even see their
child with the chains on ah with a
chainsaw very good doctor alright if you
weren't so disgusting I would probably
hang out with you alright
oh my god trampoline that's don't need
that out goddamn it stop
what do I do [ __ ] all right got it
Abilene we can do a breast Genesis
crisis is [ __ ] intense mate look how
far on the left that we have to climb on
this [ __ ] [ __ ]
jesus [ __ ] that Christ oh my god
Taylor Swift is here I'd be so much
happier I don't understand how am I
suppose to climb like a mouse when I
don't even have any sighs where's my
salad roads I owe to the south there we
go
it's okay doing good I can create a
block all right we'll make one right
here
throw it like a pokemon check fine
whoa okay here comes the shame sawing
part which is not my favorite part I
love a lot of parts if you know what I
mean ladies hello hey I'm at the top I
did it oh yeah
what the [ __ ] are those things shame on
you you mean that money all right well
this game needs to hurry up with the
blocks bet minecraft stole plagiarize
this game I called it before anyone else
not sly [ __ ]
wait do the spider move no thank you
you thought we were [ __ ] arrows where
we unfucked until the lady says suck I
rind almost I'm very proud of myself
yes so it's okay um I'm over it okay did
it beautiful staircase 100% it's not
even 100% I don't know why I said now I
feel bad two hundred idol East great
monologue on here P it's very
entertaining
it's one of them my god
oh [ __ ] okay well that's kind of useful
there's another trembling okay what know
that was unfair come on man I thought we
could do it I got to redo all that this
is why this is why babies should not
have changed all like I've said in my
entire life maybe I've been like a
spokesperson for Shane saw babies and
the Association can donate only by
paypal in the description I don't trust
anything right now I hear the bell the
Bell is Belling it up come on Bruce oh
yeah boy that's what I'm talking about
oh that's all right what a day what a
day I'm gonna have to have that episode
there cuz I've been playing for [ __ ]
almost two hours this video is probably
not
no [ __ ] you chains up oh my god
so hot
Bros next episode will be a bunch of
stories and I've seen like that one
don't miss it
maybe like if you enjoy bros do it right
now I know you want to do it and fix me
daddy